signing these documents effectively
Heralds the end of a century of colonial
and post-independence French presence in
ner on the tarmak the last of the troops
lined up to board two transport
planes their depart is marked by a rally
in front of the same base the French
called home just hours before supporters
of the K here are
elated we need the new rulers to Forge
trade and defense relations with
countries that will treat us with
fairness and respect this day we
consider as our day of
independence njer is now left forging a
sahelian alliance with Mali and Burkina
Faso to secure its borders and bring in
Goods the French began pulling out of
ner since October 10 after the Junta
cancelled all defense agreements with
the former colonial power the departure
of the last friend soldiers marks the
end of Decades of French military
presence here in njer the relationship
between the two countries deteriorated
sharply since the July coup largely due
to French opposition to the military
take
over the French have moved out all their
military hardware to France and some of
it to neighboring chai leaving Behind
these
structures these will be quickly
occupied by troops from the United
States and Germany who still maintain
some defense agreements with nja
analysts say neru has upset
long-standing relations with many
countries among them
France it's the military and its
supporters that chased out the French
not the general populace I think
restoring democracy will normalize
everything with the International
Community the French Leave ner not on
the best of terms anding Decades of
political economic and defense
engagements it's not clear if these
broken relations could be mended anytime
soon
Ahmed alaz n
Nish make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz